I want to have meaningful discussions
that I don't want to be heavy about it I
hate heavy I hate dark there's enough of
that like coming at us at all times so
how do we find the light how do we find
the answers how do we find the happiness
happiness is not on tap every morning
it's not just readily available it's
like this thing you have to fight for
and then the reward is happiness but you
earned it it isn't just being given out
for free unfortunately and there are so
many things happening outside these
walls we want to be a bright spot not a
blind spot and it is hard sometimes to
find the hope and the good it's there
are so many difficult things everybody
is contending with in this world the
whole world and so I just want to come
here and mine for the gold and the good
every day because it is there and it is
out there and I just thank you so much
for like doing that with us